und wir sprechen nun weiter über die
kleinkriminalität und auch über die
lösung und die erste frage geht an
vehement und zwar über die strukturen
innerhalb der clans welche werte
vertreten sie und wie kann man sich so
eine kleinfamilie eigentlich vorstellen
zunächst einmal als absolut geschlossene
gesellschaft insofern glaube ich auch
nach den vorfällen von duisburg nicht
dass man sich leichter methoden wird die
motive und die hintergründe dieser
schießerei die der stattgefunden hat
aufzuklären weil egal wie verfeindete
sind eins haben sie alle gemeinsam
nämlich mit der polizei nicht zu reden
und staatliche institutionen
strafverfolgungsbehörden die polizei
nicht als solche anzuerkennen die ihnen
irgendwelche autorität vermitteln können
das haben sie alle gemeinsam mit der
polizei sie hassen wie polizei und sie
verachten die polizei auch und verachten
auch diesen ganzen staat und seine
freiheitliche ordnung das haben sie alle
gemeinsam mit der polizei zu sprechen
ist sozusagen ein absolutes no go das
funktioniert überhaupt nicht und deshalb
werden wir sehr schwierig haben und
deshalb kann man beispielsweise in
diesen kreisen auch mit vielen
kriminologischen instrumenten gar nicht
umgehen man keine verdeckten ermittler
dort einschleusen weil man eben dazu
gehören muss sozusagen und weil jedes
familienmitglied auch bekannt ist da
kann man nicht irgendeinen einschleusen
denn man sagt so jetzt spielt zumal ein
bisschen klaren mitglied und vom mittel
zur die information sie kennen die szene
auch aber er sogar mit welchen zusammen
gelebt als einziger deutscher wie ist
denn das wertet auch mit blick auf die
frauen also das ist ein gutes stichwort
denn man muss 11 ich mir erstmal ganz
wichtig wir reden natürlich das thema
der sendung claims ich würde ich warne
davor dass wir das jetzt verabsolutieren
ein großteil der menschen die in
neukölln leben muslimischen glaubens
sind sind hoch anständige leute
haben
nur immer klar ich wollte gern draußen
kann der eindruck entstehen davor war
das möchten wir nicht nein ich möchte
das auch ernst aber es gibt natürlich
das was sie beschreiben
die familien dort und das sage ich eine
gewagte these die braucht nicht nur frau
bringt nicht nur freunde ein sind zum
teil viel geschlossener die normalen
familien das familien von der
familienverbund spielt eine viel größere
rolle ist auch in asien der fall die
die eltern also eigentlich frauen bei
der 50er jahre mit
auch noch man natürlich mit der frauen
besessenheit hier das der sendung werden
in deutschland dominiert von sieben
quatsch thema
ein riesenquatsch thema ich rede über
die ernsthaftigkeit das familien wenn
ich nicht das ist die 50er jahre zurück
hervor so ist zwar ein kleines baby da
kann ich nicht so gut erinnern so also
insofern
ist es so dass also in den familien da
ist der vater ich glaube dass berichte
dass man schon mal ist ich werde gar
nicht während hier ist der markt der
alte hre ältere opa der alte weiße dumme
alte mann der rc von oma zeitgeschichte
weder im bergischen kultur ich war komme
aus thailand war gerade vier jahre in
thailand tätig in bangkok da lachen die
nur über so eine kleine schießerei ja
nur meine welt so und dann ist die
situation hier halten wir also auch
darüber lachen müssen wir uns noch
vergehen ich vermute ich mal im nächsten
jahr das ist erst der anfang aber wir
werden eine situation haben dort ist er
für die unsere gesellschaft bietet
keinerlei identität keinerlei
möglichkeiten aus laptop und konsum und
wo liegt die identität im wertesystem
der clans in welchen familien müssen nur
wissen sie was wir überhaupt
vernachlässigen das sind menschen die
kommen also einer anderen kultur und die
haben ein ganz anderes verhältnis zur
religion
ich habe mich stunden und nächtelang mit
leuten unterhalten über den islam und
über das frauenbild des islam wie ist
denn jetzt dass frauen bei des islams
sie müssen wir die anweisen dürfen wenn
ja nicht schön bleiben die werden
gefesselt gehalten und kriegen
hundenäpfe hingestellt so stellen sie
sich das vor und werden mit großen
schwarzen tüchern umhüllt einverstanden
so stelle ich mir es nicht
ehrenmorde
also dass wir es so nennen dass wir es
einfach so in dieses schwerste bord ist
ein arabia ist schwerstkriminalität aber
das erst vor kurzem will ich ihnen was
sagen hier kritisiert jeden
dritten tag in deutschland wird eine
frau von ihrem ex oder von ihrem mann
ermordet und das dass wir hier in
deutschland in eine westliche demokratie
einfach im ort sagen als ob es
ausreichen wird alle 44 minuten eine
frau von einem mann erschlagen nummer zu
ihrer information haben
ich will doch weil die immer wieder
bestimmt das denken die leute eine
relativierung und jetzt keine regierung
gerede über fakten ja wir können es mir
etwas relativiert
vorher etwas zu frauen gerne und zwar
ohne ist zu werten wir kritisieren bei
den islamischen familien dass der mann
bis zu vier frauen haben dort das sagen
wir das ist völlig daneben
so sage ich mal was ist denn besser ich
will nicht sagen dass das besser oder
schlechter ist in der bundesrepublik
gehen pro tag 1,5 millionen männer in
bordelle im gesamten europäischen
kulturraum wird 770 milliarden umgesetzt
oppositions bereich lieber erlauben drei
frauen zu haben dann müssen sie keine
damenbinden wesentlich bekannt dass in
diesen ländern hohes maß an songs
positionen gibt wir müssen nicht gleich
immer etikettieren verstehen sie wir
mussten einer freundin in einer freien
gesellschaft wie du hast vielleicht
fühlte sich für viele fragen wegen
prostitution an wenn sie vier ehefrauen
sind von einem mann ich habe mit solchen
frauen verhalten auf der welt
die männer von diesen frauen überhaupt
nicht zulassen dass das ist doch gar
nicht immer sind diese geschichten die
sie ausfüllen ich habe in diesen ländern
gelebt mich ja schon wissen mit den
leuten unterhalten ich war in saudi
arabien mehrere wochen das ist doch
alles ein ich verstehen sie ich bin für
toleranz ich sage wenn jemand eine
religion hat die in gewissen bereichen
wollen wir den totalitär unsere
vorstellung von sonst über stück die
intoleranz einmal die frage ein herr
siggelkow weitergeben wie viel toleranz
soll wir haben in deutschland ja
vielleicht schauen wir zu sehr auf die
werte dort herab wie würden sie das
einschätzen die debatte also ich will
mich jetzt nicht zu sehr in einer in
eine ecke zweck lassen aber ich möchte
schon sagen natürlich müssen auch
menschen die in unser land kommen sich
an unsere regeln halten und wir müssen
aber ihnen auch die möglichkeit geben
sich an diese regeln zu halten und
bestimmte dinge vorgeben und wir haben
in den 50er 60er 70er jahren haben wir
versagt in unserem land wir haben gesagt
multikulti macht was ihr wollt und sind
selber schuld an bestimmten strukturen
die wir heute haben wenn ich in der
politik höre wir lassen menschen ins
land die sich nicht registrieren müssen
müssen wir uns nicht wundern dass hier
menschen rein kommen die nicht
registriert sind und machen das sie
wollen
natürlich ich will jetzt nicht den islam
hier einem stempel aufsetzen und sagen
alle muslime haben vier frauen und die
sind alle schlechten und sonst irgendwas
ich weiß dass die mütter im islam eine
ganz große rolle in der erziehung spielt
also nicht die väter sondern die mütter
ich habe auch ganz viel mit müttern zu
tun hier sind die christliche
einrichtung und haben trotzdem
massenweise von muslimische menschen die
zu uns kommen und sich auch uns
anvertrauen obwohl wir anders gläubig
sind sag ich mal aber es gibt eben die
extreme und bei den extrem müssen wir
eben gucken wo haben wir für sonja da
ist sie liegen ja auch ganz wichtig auch
hier für die sendung wir wollen nicht
den islam irgendeiner form ist ganz klar
unklaren familien und die werte in den
klaren dass auch nicht um den islam
sondern es geht nur um einen menschen
der dahinter steckt das sind menschen
die versuchen sich anzustrengen das
versuchen sich mühe zu geben denen man
aber nicht unbedingt gesagt hat so in
den 50er 60er jahren du musst jetzt
deutschland ja dafür gibt's ja schon
anders viele sprechen ja gar kein
deutsch die leben 30 jahre in unserem
land und sprechen die sprache nicht und
sprache ist ja letztendlich auch
integration das heißt da haben sich auch
viele gar nicht integriert das haben wir
aber auch zugelassen wir haben es nicht
gemacht und da liegt der fehler